how hard it is to be that mean to harry
mellon he is like the sweetest
individual in the world
because uh yes he played harry his
name's harry melling
and you i mean that was exciting for you
to do a scene with harry melling a
moment
yeah yeah it was her rihanna
tell us why tell us why he meant so much
to you well i
learned to speak english reading the
harry potter books so as lame as it
sounds those characters really were my
first friends
um so still a big fan of the harry
potter franchise love the movies
oh my god look at him he played dudley
dursley i mean he's not an obvious one
but so many people don't come up to him
all the time
he's still part of the universe
and so what what language were you
speaking when you learned
to speak english through harry potter
spanish
okay and yeah so when did you come to
london
when i was six but i only learned
english when i was eight because i was
convinced that if i didn't speak the
language my parents would have to take
me home
and that failed miserably so i had to
learn
and the the chess set sails all over the
world have gone
through the roof and mel gedward here
you've you've got into it haven't you
yes
and yeah um i've got to say we have now
started playing chess
regularly in our household because of
you
it's it's written yeah my daughters have
really involved it's fantastic
well well i have to tell you this so
this is going to sound really random but
being in beth's head space the whole
time was quite an intense experience
and i had never seen bake off before and
i
clung to vape off whilst i was filming
queen's gambit the whole time
like any time i was in a costume change
i was watching bay pop so you were right
there with me
and yeah i'm not in it anymore
i started i started from the very
beginning because i'd never seen it
before oh hang on
not series one where the the the hairdos
the styling was tested
one lady i was
a classic there it gets better series
three canonical public service bake off
yeah
yeah you started out in theater and when
you were a student a theater student
you had a mysterious benefactor
did you not oh great expectation
uh yeah i i went to
i did a summer exchange at the british
american dramatic academy
at baillio college in oxford um
i didn't have the money to pay for it
but one of my teachers at that time was
well she would come in for a weekly
class felicia rashad
uh people a lot of people know from the
cosby show she would come in and do a
class at howard
and so she wanted us to you know
audition for this program
and you know it was nine of us she got
some of her friends to pay for it and so
my benefactor
would ended up being denzel washington
wow so
all right you know i found that out did
i did you play him
you sound like him sorry
he's not exactly like him so you know
the funny thing is he
he showed up at the new york premiere of
black panther
and i had never told anyone you know
about that
and uh you know he comes in the back and
he thinks he's sneaking in and ryan
coogler the director
we're there and i'm like you know it's
great to meet you
big fan of your work i just wanted to
tell you thank you
for paying for me to go to to oxford he
was like oh you owe me money
so yeah yeah
and after black panther you can pay him
there
he i just did a movie that he produced
and so he got me cheap
you know are your kids got them do they
get what
they do they have no idea have they ever
seen you
no well we went to see
cars two once they're five and three
and um and when we were standing in line
for popcorn it was at the same time that
johnny english reborn was
in the theaters and so i was handed a
box of popcorn that had
me as the character on the front of it
and my little boy said that the
five-year-old said mom
it's you and i said and he grabbed it
and he started turning it around
i said what are you doing he said
where's daddy
[Music]
that's so sweet like it's family popcorn
yeah and that's the extent of it
because as a young child you played
football but like to a really high level
you could have been a professional i was
yeah i was pretty
pretty decent yeah yeah really no way
who fought i'm joking
oh my god
do you like football i do like football
yes
i do do you watch it i do i watch it
when it's the
thing that happens every four years
[Applause]
and i think you know on a movie like
this you're spending all this time
together you have to get on you are
buddies but
on silence of the lambs is it true that
did you never speak to anthony hopkins
no never spoke to him he was scary
i mean the first day we had a reading we
had like a little read through and we
i got there early and then i went to the
bathroom and i came back everybody was
sitting down we did the read through the
of the film and by the end of it i never
wanted to talk to him again i was
petrified um and so then we did the
whole movie he was always behind those
the glass partitions or he was in his
cell and because the scenes were so long
they'd kind of lock him in at the
beginning of the day and
he'd go there and then the next day he'd
be on the other side and i'd be i i'd be
on this side and we got to the end of
the movie and it really had never had a
conversation
but you never passed backstage in a car
no i avoided him
as much as i could uh i really avoided
him and then uh
i was eating a tuna fish sandwich it was
the last day and he came up to me and he
i guess he was settled up to me and i
said i i don't know i sort of had a tear
in my i was like i was really scared of
you and he said i was scared of you
i think it's funny because why would
anyone be scared of me
so so when you were filming the the
scene
you know i'm available would you do that
again
when you were filming the scenes when he
was behind the partition while they were
reset cameras you just
sat there well yeah because they were he
was screwed in you couldn't i couldn't
get to him he was
behind the glass did he stare at you um
sometimes he did you
man he's always saying my name like that
you know because
this is good john got his star wars cash
and he i don't know where you hit but
you hit a shop
a wonderful shop yeah and you have
bought
some stuff so uh you you've very kindly
brought some pictures of some of the
things you want
yeah they did so your your bed at the
bottom of your bed what have you got uh
i've got some
lions sculptures some clients yeah so
he's got
his bed but no
those are like those are like trinkets
compared to what else we've got
but the reason why i bought that is
because i feel like my spirit animal
is a lion i just feel that you know i am
african
i am yes
that's why you bought the lions why did
you buy the saxophone
lamp oh man there's no reason for that
man
that was glorified nonsense i can't lie
to you
yeah i don't mean no i mean i mean i was
in australia
and this dude just told me that there's
a saxophone with a light bulb with it
yeah something in my brain said to me
bye yes by the way i made a lamp out of
my father's clarinet
so
well there's a we have a thing it has
something to do with some
thing that we have we share you're like
a lion i like i'm like
a lion kind of yeah i could do that yeah
how about that okay you have a saxophone
lamp and i have a clarinet
yeah and goldie can i just ask you do
you have a more attractive bulb in yours
that is an ugly ass bulb john
that's one of those economy light saving
world it's environmentally friendly
yeah it's environmentally friendly
maybe or something that just yeah yeah
then as you so you we've been in the
bedroom we've now i don't know where
that is but we've walked past that's my
living room
where do we find this that's in the
corridor
okay is it an antique
um nah just quite off uh gumtree or
something you know
okay but it's it's it's just a replica
i'm just a big fan of weird things i
told you i'm 73 deep though
wait wait wait though here's the
excitement have you ever played it
you're in
john's house you want to go to the
louvre yeah so you've seen the lines
you're excited the saxophone lab is
brilliant i
really enjoy that helmet on the way to
the toilet give it to you you get into
the loo
okay you sit down you do your business
you need a little bit of toilet paper
in john's house this is who gives it to
you
boom
[Applause]
i wish i was with you it's very surreal
it's very surreal being sort of knowing
that i'm about to appear on the screen
behind you and also quite quite creepy i
would say
well now after when we have people on
zoom i say where are you and normally
it's ola or new york or something but
you
have an interesting unusual answer where
in the world is rosamund pike
she is in snowy central europe uh any
guesses from our
studio contestants as to which uh city
i mean i don't know which would shed
which central european shed you down
i'm in prague i'm in prague oh okay
so you and your husband your kids are
all there and
you've been learning a language is this
right well yeah um
i've been i've i have been trying well
i've i've i've got my kids homeschooling
me because my kids speak
mandarin which and i and i don't and um
they grew up bilingual really because my
partner thought that if he was going to
have
kids for more kids he has
he had four already um he thought it
might be exciting to talk to them in a
language he didn't already know
so he taught himself chinese from the
ground up in a very sort of well you
could call it brilliant or you could
call it
you know really stubborn or you could
call it a kind of desire for single
parenting
uh because you know he's basically
talking to them in a language that i
don't understand so i thought that maybe
lockdown was an opportunity for me to
catch up
um and so yeah so that's been that's
been i should really be learning czech i
am aware of the irony of living in the
czech republic and learning chinese
um can you can you give us some mandarin
well uh there's this thing that might my
kids i i said i said i think graham
might want to
to hear something in chinese i said what
do you think i should i should say
and they said
and i said all right great that's that's
great what does that mean and they said
that's the
act of taking your trousers off to fart
oh
wow um
[Applause]
and they said you know so that can be
lobbed you know someone who's
you know maybe for you gordon you know
if you put in a sort of ingredient
that's unnecessary or you just
you know you you go through a stage in a
recipe that's just a bit too far that
would be like taking your trousers off
too far
oh i see it's like butter on bacon that
kind of thing yeah
yes kind of thing yeah i could teach
well they could
i should have got them to teach you
really anyway i think that's a useful
phrase if you're going to know one thing
in chinese that's that's not bad
yeah and obviously you know as actors
you're you're getting into kind of you
know the emotional truth of the scenes
and all those things
but equally you've got to be like
charles and diana
so what are the shortcuts to get into
say charles what are the shortcuts right
right yeah it goes
right okay i'll get ready with a stick
spinning image so there's a couple of
things that i
sort of i mean i didn't spend too long
kind of dwelling on the little charles
things
but there was one thing i noticed that
in every time he got out of a car
he'd do this thing still does it now i
saw something recently
anyway he gets out of the car and he
goes cufflink
cufflink so he goes checks the cufflink
checks cufflink checks his pocket square
and then waves so every time he goes to
a public event or anything
it's cufflink cufflink pocket square i
wonder if he's ever not had his pocket
square and then it's completely
yeah yeah
yeah slightly yeah yeah
without the grunt when he waves yeah and
and he does speak in a very
kind of uh because it must be hard not
to just do an
impression because people do do
impressions of him i think i think
so much about the crown is sort of doing
a bit of that sort of work i don't know
what you think emma but i think it's
kind of finding little things that make
people feel safe in the knowledge that
you're not just
doing some something random for me you
feel like it is
you recognize something of charles so
with charles for instance
uh he does the thing he just thinks his
voice
where he sort of like speaks yes
so everything's like through teeth he is
yeah and actually emma's amazing
we have competitions charles and diana
and i'm rubbish at diana but she's very
good at charging
what are the shortcuts for diana um
diana's
for her voice um it's mainly that
everything goes
sort of goes down at the end so her
pattern of speech so it's sort of like
my word to get into her was always like
um was always all right
all right yeah that's just what i'd say
all right
but then everything she says sort of um
always goes down at the end so
it's almost like even if she had the
best time ever it would always sound a
little bit
sad but it's very
[Applause]
yorker did it good i used it i used to
spend most of my time trying to perfect
my all right
oh do it do it um hang on you do it with
a tilt the head tilt
all right
thank you oh yeah that's
you've had some practice now with the
the big celebrity because obviously the
golden globes yeah so who did you meet
at the golden globes
ah how long you got man it's just like
oh
so did you meet these guys the golden
globes no
i met her before it was awards
governor's governor's awards and she was
really cool when we just spoke about
stuff it was really nice
good story
because his accent was so flawless and
get out and i was like oh my god
and anytime i meet anyone who's english
i'm just
immediately like i love london i miss it
do you live there
oh yeah
at the same time it was like it was just
this segway it was just this like
this i don't know like african-american
excellent segway of black ex
i don't know what happened it's like
denzel came up to me i was like oh
he came to me english accent was like
yeah mate yeah cheers mate cheers mate
cheers mate and i'm like
what's happening how do you know who i
am and he was like and then he went to
his wife like
he thinks i don't know who he is and
then uh and then he goes call me oprah
and then i was like
bro let me oh and then and then i just
yeah i hugged her i hugged her so
tightly she felt so good man
yeah she felt she felt good apparently
she smells rich she has an amazing smell
amazing graham like i swear like oh it
is just
you premium have all met oprah does she
smell amazing i've never met oprah but
when i do i'm going to hug her for sure
the golden globes but she was too far
away you're going to inhale deeply
inhale deeply was suddenly such a nice
smell in the room
olivia we should say you join us
literally join us tonight hot foot from
the set of your other
queen job qe2 in the crown yes
and where are you are you nearly
finished or
i feel like we're uh we're nearly at the
end
which feels like the longest bit you
know and we've been going for months
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but you're
nearly there
no no nearly there yeah and for you
because
it seems to me that because of the way
this is happening you're basing it on
kind of
two people because there's obviously the
real queen elizabeth
yes but then are you in any way having
to be a continuation of claire four yeah
my first few weeks i was just
trying to do an impression of claire so
i was thinking what would claire do
i had to channel claire and then uh now
it was you know
sort of so busy i've forgotten so i
might not be doing anything like the
queen or claire now
but isn't there a thing that because
you're
you're the mobility of your face is not
something that
our lovely queen shares
so how hard is that i'm suspended from
the ceiling
it's quite hard well so if other
characters are saying something that's
sad
i naturally can't help myself i go and
birthday
which is not what the queen does she is
our rock she is not often
not not caught on camera yeah and um so
uh they film quite a lot from the back
of my head on those
days and also they've come up with a
trick so they give me an earpiece and
they play the shipping forecast to me
so i just have to try and tune into the
shipping
and that which is rude because i'm not
really listening to my fellow actors i'm
just trying not to listen to them
that's good we'll remember that when we
watch it yeah
i hope you can faintly hear it yeah
what's happened to you it's just amazing
it's wonderful you know that that
you know you're very successful in this
country and much beloved
but now you see kind of the world
discovering you and
but like but now you see you in things
like vogue and all these things
doing high fashion shoots and stuff like
is this what you dreamt of is this great
at last at last
um no that's um i love my job very much
i love it i love going to work
which is i know very lucky yeah yeah
yeah um uh
but the other stuff is a bit
embarrassing
but do you have to do it do you have to
kind of rock up you have to do it i
think i've been sort of persuaded to do
it
i don't really know do you know if you
have to do it
i think they tell you you have to do
quite a lot you have to yeah you you do
a lot yeah
yeah we don't have to do it but do they
say but they persuade no you have to
yeah because like i i don't know that i
do but then suddenly you find yourself
it's important it tries it yeah they say
that they say that yeah they do say that
a lot
i said you had to do this right yeah
even i've been told i have to do this
genuinely even though they absolutely
did
but this is genuinely one of the things
that's really enjoyable to do oh bless
i mean that oh oh it's very sprinkled
happy new year no but didn't you you had
your own cocktail
i had the margarita
[Laughter]
and what are you doing
but i ended up having uh you know i'd
start early and i'd had my
my thursday night crowd yeah partially
because
and i'm sorry sean mcpherson wherever
you are
i gave away a lot of free drinks
it wasn't a great quality in a bartender
but you were good
dealing with with uh drunk customers
which is a i had to deal with a lot of
drunk people yes
and sometimes they were not very nice
no there'd be nights where i'd be up to
my eyeballs and a-holes
um i'm saying nothing
can i keep going i don't know what's
going on
wasn't there a guy who wanted uh was
there a drunkard oh i get it yeah
wasn't there a drunk guy it wasn't that
kind of bar
was there a drunk guy who wanted uh
sambuca yes there was okay tell us about
him so
occasionally um you would get someone
who was so obnoxious
and uh it was the end of the night and
this guy came in
and he's like and he was wasted and he
was
such an a-hole and uh he's like i want a
zampooka
i'm like come on man you you're doing
okay
you're like give me a zambooka
and did he hit his knee like that
i thought yeah give me a zamboca i'm
like okay so i
pour on the sambuca light it
i'm not gonna let you drink man i don't
like drinks
okay you want to let your drink you let
you drink yourself light it
okay i light the drink
he takes it and it goes
all over his face dripping down his face
blue flames everywhere
and i'm trying not to laugh
and he
beats the hell out of himself to get it
out
give me another
no sure thing
you want me to light it for you
yes same thing
it was one of the greatest nights
i sort of like him for having another
one
i love him he walked out with like uh
like a
a flaming red goatee
[Music]